نعم اذا كاميرات العربيه ترصد وتواكب ايضا
المعتبرين والزوار ودخولهم وايضا حركه
خروجهم من المسجد الحرام الى مقر اقامتهم
والعكس كذلك طبعا كما نشاهد من خلال
الكاميرا التي نرصدها الان
ويتبين لنا ايضا اعداد المعتمرين الذين
يطوفون في صحن المطاف وايضا الموقع الذي
اتواجد فيه وهو في الطابق الثالث وهو احد
الطوابق التي خصصتها السعوديه بان تكون
مهيا ومجهزه للمعتمرين وبما اننا نتحدث
تحديدا في هذا الوقت وهو وقت الذروان
نشاهد اعداد المعتبرين الذين يقومون
بالطواف في الطابق الثالث وايضا رغم اننا
نتواجد في الطابق الثالث ولكن نشاهد في
هذا الطابق ايضا دورين او طابقين ايضا
العلوي هو خصص للعربات المتحركه والك
وكذلك الطابق الثالث وهو السفلي يعتبر الى
قسمين قسم للمشاه وقسم ايضا خصص للعربات
المتحركه
والكهربائيه ويتبين لنا كيف هي الحركه
السلسه وفق خطه تنظيميه يشرف عليها قوات
ورجال امن من قوات امن الحج والعمره هذه
بعض الخدمات التي او الخدمات التي تقدمها
السعوديه اليوم وهي تعتبر من ضمن الخطه
التشغيليه الثانيه والتي بدات فيها
السعوديه بعد ان اعلن الرئيس العام لرئاسه
شؤون الحرمين عن نجاح الخطه الاولى في
العشره الاوائل طيب ماذا لدينا في الجهه
اليسرى هنا في ايضا نواكب ايضا في الصوره
الاخرى صحن المطاف وكذلك ايضا نرصد
الطوابق الاخرى التي خصصتها رئاسه شؤون
الحرمين في ايضا منح المعتمرين كذلك دخول
الزوار وايضا تحت لهم امكانيه فرصه
الاستفاده من الطوابق الاخرى كي يقومون
باداء اركانهم طبعا عندما نتحدث ما هو
الفرق بين الخطه الاولى التشغيليه وكذلك
الخطه التشغيليه الثانيه فاننا نتحدث
اليوم ان الخطه التشغيليه الاولى كان هناك
عدد الابواب المتاحه لدخول المعتبرين
والزوار اكثر من 166 بابا سوف يضاعف عدد
الابواب في الخطه التشغيليه الثالثه او
عفوا الثانيه بحيث يصل الى اكثر من 200
باب وايضا المياه زمزم التي يستفيد منها
المعتمر والزائر ايضا سوف تكون هناك بدلا
من استهلاكهم في المرحله الاولى اكثر من
15 مليون لتر سوف يضاعف هذا الرقم قد يصل
الى 25 مليون لتر قد يزيد عن هذا الرقم
وايضا
زياده عدد العربات المتحركه وكذلك
الكهربائيه سوف يضاعف الى عدد من المسارات
في حاله احتاجه رئاسه شؤون الحرمين الى ان
تكون هناك زياده في عددها متى ما كان
اعداد المعتمرين وكذلك الزوار في ازدياد
هذه هي الحركه الطبيعيه وهذا هو الوضع
الحالي الذي تواكبه كاميرا العربيه هنا في
الطابق الثالث وكذلك من الكاميرا الاخرى
وايضا الكاميراتها المنتشره على المسجد
الحرام من خلال حركه المعتقلين والزوار
شكرا جزيلا لك من الحرم المكي الشريف اذا
المراسل العربيه نصفين